今日は卒業論文中間発表2日前に迫った肇社長です今日はこちらを使いますコンビニと
かで見かけたからみんな知っていることでしょうこちらとんがりコーン分
私はいいと小指を好きだと思ってるよ今在庫のとんがりコーンを使うとある人体実験を
しようと思っております相手このとんがりコーン切ってみるとわかるんですけどもう8
8 o
ねハーイわたしはとんがりコーンの見た目に目をつけたわけだ
おいかでちょっととんがってるわけなんですけどもうこれを本当
立つと体重をかけてみます
意外と今結構つから強くおっさんで書いたサイズをかけてもう惇也香
コーン状になっているのでそれ場所が9一点集中しますねこの一点集中した後に回りに
com で分散
分散されるからは非常に重さには強い作りになっているスナックがショ撮ってるわけ
です今回はこちらに音が以降もできる化け
3洞穴が本来はこちらにとんがりコーンなるべくたくさんあるおいしますで町の防災
実験はどんなにコーンで人は
いくことができるのか今だこちらのナマ乳お姉超すだれ米こちらに8村内君を帯び c
敷き詰めてその上に私ドクターかで目から乗って果たして受けるかどうかあの音がや
無理な企画じゃないと思ってることでわざと
いけそういつもなんてこういうのは咳ないしょみたいなフラグ回収みたいな今回は
ちょっと違うねほんとにできるかどうかも未知数ですと指でさっそく外へ飛んだりこう
セッティングしていきましょうよ
宮地ポン酢にはこの程度しか思い浮かばないだろうと街コンどんどんか断っ
お願いまあ体重65キロで
一つの豚大根だけ置いてやると体重が65キロかかりますそれ直し2つになると一つの
丼子にかかる体重は
32.5km っつになると一つにかかる体重は16.25キロというふうに数増やし
ていくだけでもかなり大幅に一つのトンガリこと
かかる重力交わされてきてるわけなので結構たくさんのリョウクと本当に多分普通に僕
が乗れると思っております
パルシェの公開だかにあったジャンです
マックが出てしてえっ
なんでー
外側の逸話ある山田
はい完成しました
大体こんな感じだと思います
んの
ん約450個の豚な2号を立てました
そして
京阪旧南紀は私の体重が65キロとんがりコーンの風が450個あるので60号 r
0.14熱0.14キロの多さが一つのとんがりコーンあたりにかかるという形態に
なっております
伝えられるかもしれないこれ本当にね読めない本当に読めない実験なのでさっそく行っ
ていこうと思います
いたをしています
腰椎支えはないよ
コケ意気だぞ午後どこを求刑4つ位
っていうパソびっくりね数値まで落とされていきます4
普通
ん
パパ中は考え難い
4を
おっテリーはいない